we have seen what natural and whole
numbers are the whole numbers comprised
of the entire set of natural numbers and
zero so what are integers then let's
zoom in a bit along with whole numbers
the set of integers also includes
negative numbers like minus 1 minus 2
minus 3 and so on we have numbers like 1
2 3 and so on so that we can count we
also know why we have a 0 now the
question why negative numbers the most
basic example would be temperature the
temperature can go below 0 degrees and
the temperature below 0 degree is
negative like minus 10 degrees let us
see a different example suppose you gave
your friend 100 rupees and that friend
returned just 50 rupees what is the net
amount you have now the net amount you
have is minus 50 rupees we know there is
no note available in the market which
amounts to minus 50 rupees but a
negative sign tells us that you are in a
loss coming back to integers all these
numbers are integers we zoom up slightly
to understand another interesting
concept the numbers 1 2 3 4 5 and so on
are called positive integers and numbers
minus 1 minus 2 minus 3 and so on are
called negative integers we can also
define natural numbers as positive
integers then what about 0 well it's
neither positive nor negative now look
at all three of them together it tells
us that all natural numbers and whole
numbers are integers the set of integers
would look something like this and the
set of integers are represented by the
letters set now we know what integers
are and why they are used
you